i regret every life choice
that has led up to this moment
i came across a fart in a jar
for sale and i'm about to buy it
how how does this work how do you sell a
fart how do you buy a fart
let's find out i'm on ebay right now i
am checking out their fart selection
there's one fart in a jar that costs
19.99 buying it how do you even know
you're getting a real
fart you have to take a real leap of
faith on that
as i browse for farts in a jar i'm
realizing this is
100 a sex thing uh
i'm not interested in the sexual aspect
of farts in a jar
if other people are good for them i just
want to see
what happens when you buy a fart i found
one that was
250 dollars and i was like i don't know
this seems like too much then i went
back on ebay and saw that the auction
had ended
nobody bought the 250 fart and the same
seller
put what appears to be the same fart
back on ebay for only
25 so i'm bidding on it now
what a savings people are about to send
me farts in the mail
i don't know why i thought that was a
good idea
i'd also just like to point out that
multiple people
signed off on me spending money on farts
is it true that when i pitched the idea
of buying a fart in a jar from ebay you
said i should buy it
yes that is true i think my exact words
were you should buy more than one
so i have good news i won the auction
for the more expensive
fart in a jar uh one other person
did bid on it but i won paying 28
so congratulations to me
what's the worst part of improving my
expenses
um having to see how much of fart in the
jar
costs it's 28 do you think that's a
reasonable amount to pay
no it's literally a jar joanna all of my
farts have arrived in the mail first i'm
gonna unbox the jars and then i'm gonna
see if i can find some people to guess
what's inside the jars
and open them up these are my two farts
that i bought on ebay
do i want to smell a stranger's fart
no i do not i really am just curious
about the economics
of buying and selling a fart in a jar
i'm just gonna put on
gloves i do not know how these farts
were collected
i honestly don't even know if they're
real farts but
here we go this part was 20 we're just
gonna
open the farts this was packaged with a
lot of care
i mean if the jar breaks does the fart
escape i guess it's a serious issue you
have to be careful
oh god okay
so here we have it this is a mason jar
with a
fart in it that i paid 20
for that's where my life is at right now
we are going to open this jar but first
let's unbox the other one
this is the luxury fart someone else out
there tried to buy this fart
but i beat them in the auction i won out
for 28
so this is a slightly more expensive
fart seller of this
fart gave me way more information
than i could have ever expected the
seller said this fart
is very unique in its way what
i feel like this person is really
spending a lot of time thinking about
farts and i guess now
so am i after i received
this fart in the mail the seller emailed
me again
and told me that the order was
guaranteed to be
fresh thank you and then told me that
the fart came from someone who had eaten
tuna salad and hard-boiled eggs i
didn't want to know that but it makes me
think
that in the fart market that's the kind
of information you want to know this is
also a carefully wrapped jar
another mason jar another fart as of now
i smell nothing
ah
i'm gonna get some of my bravest
co-workers to open these jars
and see what's inside do you guys know
what you're gonna be smelling today
no no so you guys did agree
to smell something gross i did i'm going
to give you guys the option of wearing
gloves oh god why did you get this from
ebay
yeah oh my god just in case okay
this is how it came to you yeah it came
wrapped in the tissue oh is this a fart
this is a fart
is this a fart it is you guessed it oh
god it's a fart
how did you know that what else do you
put in a jar like this
you know why would that be your first
guess of what you would put in a jar
this is a fart jar look at this it's
empty
isn't it is it someone trapped their
fart in here and that's the
way wait is it a human bar an animal
fart
human legitly okay then what i'm
thinking is you just naked ass hold this
to your anus so somebody sat over this
with their ass
and just farted into it and i was like
joanna
is this your fart no i'm gonna start
because
i have the worst sense of smell this is
the test of our friend yeah i agree
you just better do it too here we go i'm
cracking the jar
oh really tight i really hope there's no
smell
i can't smell anything to be honest
you got duped okay here we go taking off
the ring i'm
literally sweating i'm so nervous
it looks pretty clean okay are you ready
one
two three it doesn't smell like anything
it doesn't smell it smells a little
honestly
get in there oh come sniff come here
joanna
get closer to it and then really get rid
of it get your face in there you're
ready okay yes
oh my god
it doesn't smell like a fart yeah i
think it's just the old jar
yeah i don't smell anything it smells
weird
it's so weird it smells like they put
something on it that they thought
smelled like a phone
oh you think you got duped this is
definitely somebody's kink right
yeah i mean whatever gets you going gets
you going
it's a cool jar and you can use it for
something yeah it's a really cool jar
you see they chose a mason jar so it's
artisanal i will fart into this jar
i'll do it the cheaper fart at twenty
dollars
didn't really smell like anything the
more expensive fart at 28
definitely smelled like something but i
would not describe that
smell as particularly fart-esque
it was sort of chemically if you're in
the market for farts this is the kind of
thing you can expect you're really more
purchasing the idea of the fart
we'll never really know for sure whether
or not people farted into these jars but
i
am kind of worried that i'm gonna get
pink guy now
huh